Martin Scorsese's Netflix original film
the Irishman is really getting dragged
online so the official Twitter account
Netflix film decided to do a little good
nature dragging back hey it's only fair
you can't responded to a tweet in which
it wasn't even tagged but made a joke
about the best way to watch the Irishmen
a film that was produced for Netflix but
received a limited theatrical run in a
recent interview with film critic Peter
Travers the legendary director suggested
that the Irishmen should definitely be
viewed on the biggest screen possible I
would suggest if you ever want to see
one of my pictures on most films please
hear Marty Scorsese goes on to say an
iPad a big iPad maybe well you probably
know where this is going in response to
that remark
several cheeky troublemakers took to
Twitter posting pictures of themselves
watching the Irishman on every
diminutive device known to man for
example one tweet featured a viewer
watching Scorsese's film on an Apple
watch along with the caption now
watching the Irishman the way Scorsese
intended another Joker who clearly
possesses some superior photoshop skills
seemed to be watching the film on an
old-school Nintendo Gameboy the caption
read he said I could watch on this but
the comet that drew the attention of
Netflix film came from comic book debate
lead writer Danya Harrington
she claimed I debated watching the
Irishman on my phone for this four hour
bus ride but I feel like Scorsese will
magically appear and beat my ass if I do
the Netflix account suggested that
Harrington was half right replying with
he absolutely will appear but instead of
a beating he will simply sit across from
you for the entire film and twinkle his
eyes in a grandfatherly way that says
it's okay my child formats and
presentation matter but your experience
of Arts is valid no matter how you
receive it pretty funny sure but it
doesn't really sound like something
Scorsese would say does it perhaps
that's because in recent months the
legendary filmmaker has offered up an
awful lot of opinions about mainstream
film and they haven't exactly been
well-received the great Scorsese
blowback of 2019 began with three little
words uttered during an interview with
Empire magazine in early
Tober that's not cinema the director was
referring to superhero films in general
and the movies of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe in particular needless to say
many fans of the MCU franchise along
with some actors and directors who
worked on the films took issue with that
statement
Scorsese's subsequent attempts to
clarify his remark didn't go
particularly well either as The
Hollywood Reporter noted he effectively
doubled down a couple weeks after his
empire magazine interview saying
theatres have become amusement parks
that is all fine and good but don't
invade everything else in that sense
it's not my kind of thing it simply is
not it's creating another kind of
audience that thinks cinema is that in
response to the mounting criticism over
these comments Scorsese penned an
editorial for the New York Times in
early November entitled I said Marvel
movies aren't cinema
let me explain the lengthy piece
basically fleshes out his original
statement at one point he writes many of
the elements that define cinema as I
know it are there in Marvel Pictures
what's not there is revelation mystery
or genuine emotional danger nothing is
at risk once again everyone from
guardians of the galaxy director James
Gunn to Disney CEO Bob Iger wound up
criticizing Scorsese's take on the MCU
franchise of course it must be said that
the Irishman is an excellent film
starring Scorsese mainstays like Robert
De Niro Joe Pesci and Harvey Keitel and
adding no less than Al Pacino into the
mix the Irishman has earned Scorsese
some of the best reviews of his career
it's safe to say that there wouldn't be
a controversy if Scorsese had simply
stuck to talking about his new film
while making the rounds that's not
really his style is it my concern is
losing the screens to massive theme park
films check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite movies are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]